also freunde ich war im internet
unterwegs und hab mir gedacht hey luca
du bist jetzt nicht der allerbeste
fordert spieler wäre vielleicht cool
dass eine person beibringen und da habe
ich ein angebot den text namens
fortnight pro gamer girl für nur 35 euro
74 in der beschreibung steht erst üben
in spielwiese dann anwendungen gelernt
hat dinge in einem duo match das ganze
kostet 31 euro 28 und das ganze wird
bereitgestellt von der person namens
gamer girlie 123 da habe ich mich
natürlich erstmal über diese person
informiert namens gamer girlie 123
sie hat ein paar bilder drin und zwar
dass hier oder das hier das ist das auch
toll und das hat sie auch noch also sie
ist vertraut mit controllern ich habe
mich dann auf jeden fall mit ihr in
kontakt gesetzt ich habe den betrag
überwiesen und nun ist die zeit gekommen
es ist 16 uhr
dass wir uns in der fordert lobby
treffen und sie mir das spiel bei bringt
so
wir befinden uns hier in der lobby von
ford leid und wir wurden auch gerade
schon in die gruppe eingeladen von
unserem gamer girl das heißt ich jetzt
einfach mal auf gruppe beitreten hallo
sie haben sie sprechen deutsch
okay sie sind gamer girlie 123 die ich
hier gebucht habe perfekt womit womit
fangen wir dann also ich bin halt
wirklich ein kompletter anfängern fort
dann brauche ich dafür irgendwie 1 kind
oder oder was braucht man nicht wenn man
richtiges geld
bitte lachen sie ich bin das habe ich
immer wenn ich nervös bin zudem zu dem
sie ja wissen nicht viele aber das ist
eigentlich der beste ort rauszustrecken
und da kann sie jetzt einfach mal an wo
genau das relativ egal ob man sich
vielleicht treffen ich sehe schon
gelandet ich werde sie verdienen ausrief
jetzt auch so verstehen sie keine
begrüßung
doch was ist los und erstes muss man
natürlich erstmal gesund ich habe sie
verloren
ich habe jetzt ein kleines problem
hallo
deshalb gehen wir generell mehr für den
schirm das geld
so könnt ihr hier gucken gemacht so
genanntes mit kitkat fürs mit hingehen
dann kommt immer auf die drücken drücken
habe ich was mache ich damit jetzt nicht
hier steht der kondition ist bereits
voll okay für nachher falls sich schaden
bekommen warum hab ich jetzt nichts
bekommen
ich habe ja schon das medi kit stimmt
zwar kräftig drücken was ist daran so
schwer
was also nicht komplett verarschen
wollen wir nicht mal was sie mir das
auch vielleicht mal beibringen wie man
dann auch schießt und umbauten sowie
spiel das spiel ja nicht so häufig was
machen wir doch gleich alles verstehen
nicht nur entschuldigung machen machen
sie ihr ich bin der sehr dankbar dass
sie das machen für mich soll ich jetzt
die ok dann nehmen sie die wissen dass
da hinten
dazu kommen
ok entschuldigung an sich das rad
einfach alles genommen
auch wenn damit bummelt wieso gehen sie
denn sie sind am anderen ende vom sie
jetzt hier sehen sie hier die ganze zeit
rum bedenken sie dass es spaß
warum hüpft man dann hier die ganze zeit
da wackelt so welche geschmacksrichtung
ist das können sie mir dann noch
beibringen was was machen sie gerade die
mit ihnen vorbereiten findet ohne frage
jetzt gehen wir als nützen baum
das ist mein bauch ist natürlich mein
eigentlich war das ist auch mein baum
suchen sie sich doch einfach meine
eigenen bauen dass er wohl nicht so
schwer
okay okay
und jetzt kann ich mir so ein richtiges
haus hier bauen dann bin ich jetzt
eigentlich bereit für eine richtige
runde fort oder nimmt aber dass auch das
was die ganzen profis dann immer
gewinnen und so kriegen wir dann epic
win win hin heute wie teuer werden
machen wir dann beim nächsten mal nicht
dann könnte
hallo hallo haben sie denn da jetzt den
rucksack auf die komplette volk diese
das sind sie ja gar nicht verwechselt
dann drücken wir jetzt mal enden dann
kommen sie auf die map okay da sehe ich
wo man hinkommt legen sie denn hin zu
dem punkt dachte ich okay ich bin ich
bin tot
das war natürlich meine wir sind halt
noch ein anfänger
alles eine frage der geduld und rückt
mit einer vorbereitenden hofft stoffe
nicht wieder direkt in der ersten woche
sterben deutlich dass der stress der mit
ihnen diese stürzte das nicht dass das
ist ihr beruf ja aber normalerweise
meine kunden ein bisschen fähiger dann
setzen wir hier die stecknadel hin
da können wir uns ja jetzt auch schon
ein bisschen aus so zweite runde mit
ihnen ja genau
ja okay und springt ja ich bin raus ich
zu den punkten liegen für die entweder
auf der mitte ja also wir sind auf die
insel sie denn keine angst dass die
eventuell noch andere leute sein könnten
brauchen sie eine waffe
ich habe schon eine sorry preise was
soll ich denn jetzt machen also wir
haben jetzt beide eine waffe und leben
noch
ich bin gerade raus gelaufen ich würde
jetzt mal ein paar bäume abbauen so wie
sie mir das beigebracht haben hallo
hallo
[Musik]
das wollen wir nicht nur ein paar kämpfe
wo volvo wolle ja nicht hier nicht
eingreift nicht erst kommen leute von
hinten
ich bin tot gamer girlie 123 da sind
leute tatsächlich hinter ihnen einer
merklich coole mike 1 23 teams getötet
das ist wahrscheinlich ein fake von
ihnen oder auch merken dass für den
spieler dann melden
[Musik]
also was schreibe ich dann genau so geht
das nicht aus gezeigt so geht das nicht
ausrufezeichen ok hab ich habe ich
abgesendet und dann machen wir nochmal
ne runde hatte noch nie einen kunden das
so wenig begriffen hat weiß nicht ob es
nebenbei noch irgendwas anderes mache
mit ihrer katze spät oder was auch immer
aber kann eigentlich an
und noch eine runde wenn es jetzt nicht
besser wird also dann entweder die buch
und dann noch mal ein paket oder wir
lassen nichts wirklich ich sehe sie
danke sie siegen gut danke wollen wir
haben sie lust mal was essen zu gehen
ja also müssen wir und ich muss mich
jetzt lerne ich habe da eine frage ich
glaube wir schaffen das nicht ganz jetzt
[Musik]
gemacht haben
ok also gehen wir ins haus und dann was
man tut mir leid dass ich die sachen
liegen dir sind ruhe wollen wollen wie
die dann öffnen darf
[Musik]
zu lassen sind sie nicht zum spaß dass
ich habs jetzt mittlerweile gestanden
haben ich bin tot
direkt wieder oben bringen das ich hab
jetzt echte zufolge tief reicht mir das
war schon was die hier habt ihr wirklich
da finde ich komm raus waren buchen sie
denn überhaupt was für mich das bei mir
wirklich nicht angegeben ich aber ich
dachte sie würden mir das dann
beibringen halt versuche ich ja
normalerweise sind die leute müssen
schnell auf den begriff hat die zweite
runde für mich also ja
ich kann jetzt fordert spielen an der
stelle
heute gewinnt allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren ich habe ein
video und amerika gesehen wo sich jemand
wirklich irgendwie für 200 dollar sonnen
ford neue gamer girl gekauft hat die ihm
dann ein epic win geholt hat und ich
wollte es einfach mal dumm nachstellen
und wenn es euch gefallen hat das kenne
man like da habt ihr bock dass ich in
nächster zeit ein bisschen öfter
eventuell fordert hochladen
dann versuche ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
besser zu werden mit ein paar kumpels
und dann hole ich bald auch mal die 30
also los
[Musik]